what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
well I mean you do realize this Mike's
not gonna pick you up it's like so
designed no no it's not designed to pick
up anybody else except for me like it's
like like like people are gonna think
I'm crazy talking to myself right okay
okay if you already explained the flat I
could explain the flash team I like like
well we're gonna be here for a little
while but it's like this like yeah yes
yeah okay so it's like it's like 7:30 so
it's not a great big huge deal um yeah
so god man um what do you wanna know
about the flash yeah TV shows yeah
that's pretty good
TV shows pretty good okay well I mean
really man like I mean Jay Garrick was
obviously the first flash you know I
mean he was he was he was the first one
but it all goes back to Superman and and
really even before Superman and that's
that's one of the crazy things so so one
of the big misconceptions people have
and and this is probably it was probably
this probably one that you have but one
of the big misconceptions people have is
is that back in the day when like
Superman and Batman first showed up that
all you had was like DC Comics and then
like Marvel Comics you know because a
lot of people assume that almost been
around like forever right like they've
always been there and just didn't start
publishing anything until 1960 and to a
degree that's true you know back then
you had like timely which you know had
Captain America and in with a submariner
the original Human Torch Jim Hammond and
then in the 1950s they became Atlas and
then the 1960s they became maybe was a
late 1940s but anyway somewhere along
the line that became Atlas and then they
rebranded for a third time and they
became Marvel but for for DC things were
a little more complicated I guess
and so before comic book so let's kind
of want the clock back a little bit
further and so before comic books will
say like 1931 more or less you know for
the for the time period between 1931
really like the late 1920s
going into like 1938
for this anywhere between 7 to 10 year
window you basically just had pulp
magazines right like like you know the
Phantom and Doc Savage and Phantom
Stranger I think it is but but you have
like pulp magazines and these are
basically just stories told about you
know adventures and detective work from
different things like that and some of
it was paranormal but none of it
involved anybody with any real
superpowers what you had at that time
was you had a guy named Malcolm
wheeler-nicholson and Malcolm
wheeler-nicholson was a guy who wanted
to publish comic books but didn't have
the means to do it on his own and and at
the time you had comics insofar as you
had like famous funnies which were
basically just like reprints of the
funny pages
more or less yeah yeah peanuts it was
reprints of peanuts no it wasn't but but
it was it was a reprint of the funny
pages that was thrown into like a comic
book into a comic book format and so
that turned into you know is there a
market for this and so Malcolm
wheeler-nicholson was a guy who created
like new fun comics create like his own
like the first real , but with like
original drawings and original you know
writing and all that kind of stuff
original scripts but couldn't get
anybody to publish it because people at
the time were just kind of like you know
new fun comics is selling
I'm sorry not new fun comics pulp
magazines are selling you know there's
an established market for what we're
currently doing why rock the boat why
change it and why spend all this money
cuz you gotta move man it was expensive
to publish a comic book like it was
really really pricey and so it was like
why invest all this time and money and
and something that may not even succeed
and so like like he was blown off by
everybody now eventually he ran into a
guy named Harry donenfeld who ran some
kind of like independent magazine
company or something I don't know what
it was called but he met a guy named
Harry donenfeld and Harry donenfeld ran
a publishing us and he polishes on
magazines newspapers different things
like that you know he dealt with his own
pulp magazines but but the two of them
went in business together you know Harry
donenfeld I'm sorry yeah Harry donenfeld
told Malcolm wheeler-nicholson look I'll
publish your comics but we have to
basically form a company together and so
they form national allied publications
now national allied publications was it
was an over it was the overarching
publishing house and then under national
allied publications you had
hecht of comics incorporated and that
was what comics got polish were there
only a couple of them I mean really a
handful you had like new fun comics
which was their first real real
publication then you had like more fun
comics and appreciate like adventure
comics
I think was a third one and so the idea
was that by this point in time Malcolm
wheeler-nicholson had basically been
like booted out of his own company he'd
been kicked out of his own company and
like the shadiest way ever it was it was
I don't remember the story too well
because it's been such a long time since
I read about it but it was it was it was
something like Harry donenfeld had sent
Malcolm wheeler-nicholson on a trip to
Cuba or something like that and while he
was gone he had him kicked out of his
own company or like sued him or
something like that for like failure to
be a part of the con for someone with
laws anyway he used a legal system to
oust Malcolm wheeler-nicholson and so so
Nicholson was out he was gone and and
Harry donenfeld took the company over
and so under Detective Comics
incorporated the Harry donenfeld wanted
to launch a fourth publication and it
was gonna be called action comics and
the problem with this was that their
backs were against the wall they they
had no idea how to publish this thing
and they were they were like you know
like we were well I mean they they
denied to publish it but they were like
look where we have like we have like
that much that much time you know that
much time to publish this and the what
ended up happening was you had Harry
donenfeld going to Vince Sullivan who
was the editor who was gonna be the
editor for Action Comics and you said
just give me anything I don't even care
what it is just throw a stuff in it and
and we'll send it out and whatever
whatever in the hell happens happens and
they did that
then Sullivan ended up going through
like a stack of writings he picked up
Jerry Siegel and Joe Shuster Superman
which nobody wanted to publish and and
threw it on the front cover and threw it
as a through it is the first story and
and the comic book industry was off to
the races I mean after that it was it
was it was just like like we got this
like it was unlocked out it's it's one
of the it's that's one of the crazy
things it's like Superman yeah yeah
exactly so it was it was happenstance
that's that's exactly right it was a
chance it was it was just like it was a
it was a huge risk and so so with the
arrival of Superman that basically meant
that like the superhero genre
was born you know it was it was there it
was here to stay and we knew that just
by virtue of the Superman sales I mean
I'm course I wouldn't live back then but
like you know you go and you look at any
of the numbers or you look there's a
really good historian les Daniels I
think is his name that studied like the
history of comic books and he has a
bunch of books out and stuff like that
but he talks about like you know how
Superman had basically blown the shell
like blown the doors off this comic book
industry this is the superhero genre
that nobody fully trusted and so now
like all these companies you not a
feature syndicate and like all these
companies out there we're basically
stuck with egg on their face but
suddenly like all these publishing
houses started creating like comic book
arms you know it was like like you had
quality comics and you had you had
timely comics which is part of magazine
management incorporated the time I think
you had I mean you had him all over the
place you know like Charlton comics as
well - you had him everywhere everybody
was publishing comic books now and some
of them are more successful than others
you know for example you had foster
publications which was a full magazine
company that the CEO the head of the
company what - Bill Parker and CC Beck
and he said give me Superman without
Superman and and that led to the critic
exactly I love the creation of Shazam
that led to well we call Shazam now back
then he was Captain Marvel
but Billy Batson oh he do he crush
Superman in sales oh he outsold him I
like a margin of two to one it was
insane
he could fly before Superman um he had
his own radio show before Superman I
mean he was he was way more popular
because Superman was just like a
superhero he was a grown man but Billy
Batson was a kid who could shout the
word Shazam and become you know become
Superman and so it resonated with like
young hits who were like the biggest
demographic for comic books and so the
result was that you ended up going into
into like this this post 1938 era
basically like the early 1940s
ah with Superman leading the charge of
like this huge this whole new generation
of superheroes well in addition to
national publications and they're
Detective Comics branch while you did
have a lot of other copies out there he
did have a lot of the people publishing
their own comics you know again like
timely had Captain America into the
Submariner and and the original Human
Torch Jim Hammond he had a guy named Max
Gaines and in
I want to say it was something after it
was something like six months after the
release of Superman
max gains realize how popular Superman
was and the fact that there was a market
for superheroes and so he went to Harry
donenfeld and said give me funding to
launch my own comic book company and and
we'll be like will be will be sister
companies you know essentially like
you'll you'll you'll be in charge of
national and you'll have Detective
Comics Incorporated but I'll be like a
satellite company and I'll orbit around
you and we'll call mine
All American comics and that's what he
did he founded all-american comics and
that's the irony of the whole thing is
aside from Batman and Superman pretty
much every every character that exists
in dk a DC Comics like the core members
of what would become the Justice League
they all originated in in all American
comics the original of Green Lantern
Alan Scott All American comics Wonder
Woman All Star Comics number eight she
was originally an all-american comics
character the JSA the Justice Society of
America all-american comics and Jay
Garrick was the same way Jay Garrick
originally appeared in in the flash
which is it's kind of it's kind of funny
saying this because I guess I guess I
don't even know how long this how how
long is going on for a buddy like we're
just now getting around to talking about
Jay Garrick Jay Garrick originally
appeared in in it is owned in flash
comics number one but it wasn't his own
solo series that didn't come come until
later with all flash I think is what it
was all flash number one the way that's
worked out then is anthologies were all
the rage and because it was basically a
risk free way or at least as close as
you could get to a risk free way of
publishing a wide array of superheroes
without having to worry about losing
like a ton of money because because one
thing to bear in mind is is like it was
a crapshoot I mean like when you look at
Jay Garrick he was a guy he was just
like some young kid who was working in a
science lab you know and the professor
had left you know to go do something or
he'd left for the night or so along
those lines and Jay Garrick was working
with like heavy water because it was the
Atomic Age right it was it was going
into we're not really the Atomic Age per
se but going into the Atomic Age like
World War two and the new generation of
warfare and so on and so forth and so so
you had Jay Garrick who was messing with
determined heavy water or something
along those lines and and he was
basically doused with these chemicals
and pat on so he was exposed to that to
the chemicals and then passed out and
then woke up in a hospital with the
ability to run it like the
speed of sound I'm pretty sure it was um
and so like like his sorta story it was
it's basically utter nonsense
you know like if anybody was exposed to
to deter II imagine they probably died
from radiation poisoning you know like
like though I'm not here about a story
there's a story that Marvel Marvel made
something like like ten years ago then
he was written by this guy named Warren
Ellis who has just like the darkest most
cynical view of the world and it's
called Marvel ruins and it's yeah it's
not yea covering on my channel yeah so
so Marvel ruins was a story where it was
like what would actually happen in these
circumstances and there's one there's
one segment where The Incredible Hulk
where Bruce banners blasted with like
gamma gamma radiation and everything and
instead of turning into like the
Incredible Hulk
as we know him he's just covered like
these giant blisters you know and sores
and dies almost immediately like it's
it's it's pretty gruesome and this and
it's really really dark but uh but
anyway so this this goes into you know
with with Jay Garrick you know his story
would basically nonsense but that's
what's gonna keep him on its back then
like there were no templates do it there
was no standard by which to publish a
comic book story everyone was flying by
the seat of their pants
if Marvel and DC created a story right
now you know they would have 80 years of
superheroes or 80 years of super
villains you know depending on what kind
of character they want to make they'd
have all that time to base these things
off oh you didn't have him back then
they were like Superman was the only
real template you had aside from that it
was create a character and see if they
resonate so you get like Lex Luthor and
Superman number four or something like
that you know and you know you get that
whole Superman Lois Lane dichotomy and
Action Comics and so on you know it was
eventually plan branches out into
Superman I mean it was it was literally
just like experimentation and so because
everything was a crapshoot it made a lot
of sense to publish these stories and
see how they would respond so that's why
if you go when you read flash comics
number one um I want to say the
characters that you get you of course
get the flash Jay Garrick um but you
also end up getting a Hawkman the
original Hawkman you end up getting
Johnny thunder somebody else and I can't
remember who um but but any of them it
doesn't matter yeah this is a topic of
Jay Kirk and so Jay Garrick could run
super fast and that's what that's what
you know all American built on they were
they built on the idea that he
like he was basically Superman parceled
out you know taking one of his powers
which was the ability to move super fast
and and he was popular insofar as almost
every superhero was popular back then
because they were so new you know they
were so fresh and vibrant the problem
with this this is the biggest problem
that you began to run into was that
there was some confusion here in there
because you had a company called quality
comics for example which turned around
and published a Johnny quick and then I
don't remember if it was maybe it wasn't
quality comics and I think it was
quality comment there was another
company that came along I think it was
also quality comics that published
stories involving a guy named
Quicksilver which if you look him up
you'll find out that he's actually a guy
named max mercury so so like it was it
was kind of we were the speedsters and
stuff like that they had you know well
at least the people who could run super
fast run a super speed that they had
back then but the biggest problem of the
superhero genre ran into especially with
Jay Garrick because the stories weren't
particularly good and they weren't
really memorable the biggest problem
that you ran into is that superheroes
became part and cross sort of world war
two because one more - I mean was a
total war effort but like every facet of
society was tied into World War two you
know you had Rosie the Riveter which
came out of it because all the able
brawny able-bodied men who could look it
like work they were fighting overseas
and so you know I guess with the
exception of a handful you know I mean
not really like a massive percentage but
by and large all the soldiers were men
and so that left like a huge amount of a
huge like hole in the workforce and so
you had like like all these facets of
society that were contributing to world
war ii how much for the exact same
weight like Superman Batman Wonder Woman
Aquaman the flash Jay Garrick the Green
Lantern Alan Scott and even in timely
you know Captain America when he when he
made his debut namor the sub-mariner
Jeff Hammond all these guys they all
fought and really with Bucky Barnes that
they all fought against the Axis powers
and what this meant was that it drummed
up sales even higher because it was a
way for people to participate you know
to do their part so to speak in fighting
the Axis powers by reading comics by
buying comics
contributing to the war effort and kind
of pushing forward the propaganda
machine of the United States during
through the 1940s the again the problem
with this though was that by the time
war ended the people didn't
differentiate they didn't see Superman
as a character who existed before World
War two they saw Superman as a character
who was part of world war two they
didn't see like the flash Jay Garrick or
the Green Lantern Alan Scott or Batman
or Superman I'm sorry a Wonder Woman or
Aquaman any of those characters they
didn't see them as separate from World
War two now you know the Trinity Batman
Superman Wonder Woman and even when he
got into like Aquaman characters like
that they survived because they were
just so popular because they were so
unique you know super you know when you
go and look at the old comics Batman and
Superman were almost identical the only
difference was like the powers you know
like the the the gist of their
characters you know Batman was Superman
without the powers and Lois Lane and
that was basically like they both killed
people like there was one story I'll
never forget there was one story I read
where where some guys robbed a bank or
something like that and they ended up
driving or driving they're driving their
truck down the road and as they were
flying down they ended up flying off
this this this road into a ravine worth
like the the truck exploded they died in
a fiery crash and Superman just watches
that happen and he's just like yep
that's kind of what they deserve and I'm
like Dan Superman you're kind of an
[ __ ] isn't exactly like his like
Superman's a dick like he's kind of an
[ __ ] you know but Batman I'm like
hung a guy from the batwing and he's
like well he's better off this way I
mean like they were pretty brutal uh
Wonder Woman was strange because the guy
who made her and I can't remember his
name
um he was obsessed with like bondage so
you go and you read like the old Wonder
Woman stories her weakness was being
chained up by men the guy was a guy have
some serious issues going on but still
you know they were they were they were
unique Aquaman talked to fish and so
because of these things there were very
unique characters in their regard and so
they survived the flash wasn't unique
enough he just wasn't interesting enough
and so by the by you know with with
world war ii coming on i guess i'm sorry
with world war ii ending the superhero
interest just just bottomed out I mean
there was there was no real interest
there and unless you were the Trinity
and Aquaman then you were basically pop
like you were basically cut loose and so
Jay Garrick just was just gone like he
just vanished like that was the end of
who's just gone one day and it was a
craziest thing because with or with with
the elimination of superheroes
with with those superheroes DC never
answered it you know because by that
point in time national allied
publications and their child company DC
Comics had merged with with All American
comics and then rebranded itself as
Detective Comics Incorporated and so
with them like merging together and
forming a single identity everything was
published by Detective Comics but like
they never answered the question at
least not initially I never answered the
question where did Jay Garrick go you
know what happened in the character of
Jay Garrick you know what happened in
the character of Allen Scott they never
answered any of that stuff instead it
was just like yeah they're gone you know
and then you get you that's where you
start getting into the science-fiction
realm and you start getting into into
Barry Allen you know the introduction of
his character the flash and and and so
on and so forth but um ya know Jay
Garrick his his stories weren't very
memorable he wasn't really a special
character back then he's special because
of them because of the legacy I mean he
created like like he alongside Hawkman
and and a handful of others let's see
like the specter I think it was you know
they created the Justice Society of
America the JSA and there were others
who were part of it too the first real
superhero team in comic books but but
he's more of a character who's popular
because he's the original flash you know
at least uh in terms of publication
history chronologically it's max mercury
but that wasn't established until the
mid 1990s by Mark Twain but but you know
publication wise he was the original
flash and so flash fans loved his
character because he's like old man
flash you know he's he's got like all
this wisdom that he brings to the table
you know and he's got the discus hat you
know and and whatever and bought ah but
yeah the nineteen fifties is when
everything changed
that's that's when the whole scene
totally rebooted and it was it was it
was it was kind of crazy but um yeah I
know man if we're gonna trainees in a
video it's like we should really stop
here if I'm being honest with you um no
no I mean it's I mean we don't have to
but we've been doing this for 20 minutes
so I mean yeah I figure it's a good
place to stop and then we'll figure with
like Barry Allen
you know because Barry Allen's when the
flash really gets interesting you know
that's when things really good cool you
know we're like eobard thawne kills iris
West and then Barry Allen kills a year
Bart's on it like the the pre-crisis
stories of Barry Allen were pretty
intense actually they were they were
they were kind of nuts and then it goes
into Wally West
which is which is that's what you
starting in like the multiverse crisis
on Infinite Earths and all I kind of
itself Jay Garrick comes back things
like that but yeah well we'll talk about
that well yeah well like we'll hit stop
and we'll stop the video and then we'll
just we'll fire back up again and then
what we'll turn it into you know like
make another video basically because
like I told you man I mean if we're
gonna be here for a little while if you
wanna learn everything about the flash
then you got a lot to learn man I won't
mean I will say this though man you'd
like like okay so I'm almost kind of
afraid to say it on my youtube channel
but but like I'm developing a new
celebrity crush yeah yeah man exactly
yeah Jessica Parker Kennedy man she's
the same age as me and like we have the
same skin complexion but but she seems
she seems like a nice person I don't
know I've never met her but she's like
my new celebrity crush because like
she's pretty hot so I don't know anyway
um yeah man so so yeah okay we'll go
ahead and in this and then I'm gonna use
a bathroom and then we're gonna go ahead
and have this off so and then we'll
restart it all
[Music]
[Applause]
you